right in a sense that I think you're all
Specialists and stuff we saw we've seen
a history of integer programming and all
that so what ASP is more or less about
is is a logic and approach that does the
same thing just by aiming at close World
reasons
like you have a databases for instance
so what you get actually is a
non-monotonic system
um and this is more or less what it is
so the big the big drawback of this is
there's this area had no George pool and
all the nice people we've seen on the
slides before so actually when you when
you looked at the there's actually a
famous paper that email which is one of
the Godfathers of ASP and this paper
keeps changing its title I think it's
now at 13 alternative definitions of
stable model symmetics
because there was no Theory underneath
right so people had to invent new meta
mathematics meta mathematics to
characterize things and um unfortunately
there was a rediscovery of things I will
make this as I will show you this in a
sec so let's start actually I was so
bold just to to copy the title of the of
the seminar by replacing SATA answer set
program
good so
first of all in a very bold way and a
very rough informal Warehouse ASP and
and saturated again ASP can be seen as
the non-monotonic version of set doing
close word reasoning so in a way you can
you can view it like this so if you want
to do stat and you have an asp solver
what you need to do you need to add
excluded middle
axioms for each atom so a for each atom
you add a or not a b or not b and you're
done
and on the other hand if you want if you
have a set server and you want to do ASP
with it you have to do much more so
whatever these completion and loop
formulas mean what these guys actually
do they make sure that everything that
is true in a so-called stable model also
has a finite proof
so you add this notion of you you don't
only have true and false literals you
also have provable atoms
and we will see why this will become
important actually if you model those
who know that it's there's such an
excluded middle are just Choice rules
nothing more
okay then ASP in the standard case or
but people think about it is just logic
programs so rules with with atoms in the
head and
literals in the body but in general
so if you do if you if you go up from
this normal form and you check
propositional formula complexity goes
one level higher
but also something to keep in mind that
normal phoneticity has a price here and
this actually we will see this later as
due to a minimization on things now I
thought how how else to continue and I
think an important thing to to look at
ASP is actually the different culture
that it has
so ASP is actually deeply in rooted
involved in the field of knowledge
representation reasoning and as such has
has different focuses even though the
technology is is very similar
as I you may know that we also have run
a company and I just put the pitch
slides here first so just to show you
this so if you think about and this is
normally how I argue with with companies
look in traditional programming you have
a user you have a computer you buy a
program and this does something for you
well here the idea is that you separate
actually in the tradition of declarative
programming you separate the what is the
problem question proposing the knowledge
about this from the how to solve the
problem and this is what you do with the
solver
and this has various benefits
and again this is the pitch for for this
and and the benefits is first of all the
benefit is that to pose the the actual
problem you don't need a programmer
anymore
the idea is that you actually use this
with an expert you use this with an
expert and interestingly actually in
there is people in in Sydney are doing
this they even go one step further they
can deal with natural language
specification not arbitrary but one's in
controlled natural language right and
that's a bit that that's actually the
the the idea at that point but you get
them of course you get the same type of
the same type of advantages on the solar
level but on the specification level you
have transparency flexibility mental
reliability you can prove things and all
that type of stuff hence for us
what is really important is modeling for
instance
right so it's not that you take just an
encoding and then you do something with
it no you you usually have different
ways to encode try to optimize the
encode that's normally the level we look
at
okay and then here's actually something
from Siemens which is a paper they they
published in 2016. but talk about
constrained Technologies but this
includes actually ASP and they measure
this in in their company by using these
these these type of Technologies they
believe that they save 80 of Maintenance
causing 60 of development costs
by doing that okay doing constraint
programming and doing asp
okay these were more or less the pitch
the pitch light so let's look a little
bit more into more into it so we're
still in the nutshell level
so what is what is ASP in a sense it's
it's an approach to declarative problem
solving
and what it shares with SATA of course
the high solving high performance
solving capacities
some of you may actually know our solver
class actually it's back in the day we
also won some stat competitions but
never the industrial ones right always
the crafted ones so it's really looking
at another at another type of problems
it's a modeling language in the same way
as you're having constraint programming
though I'd say it's a it has a logical
flavor it's a bit more more abstract
and you can do closed and open world
recently
and what you also get is you get
qualitative and quantitative
optimization on top of it but again all
this tailored to knowledge
representation and reasoning and
formally I think I told that
that it allows you to solve all search
problems up to the second level actually
you can even go to the third level with
data P3 because you can use this and do
optimization on top of it
but you know this is a nitpick you know
this
okay that's so in a way again the slogan
ASP then combines more or less database
techniques this is actually done to to
to process the modeling language
logic programming this is more than
where the roots are and all that
knowledge representation and of course
Boolean constraints satisfaction
okay now
I told you about these 13 different
definitions of stable model semantics
let's look a little bit in this
foundation and what we need here to do
close World reasons
now first of all if we do close word
reasoning if you have you know in in the
specification you somehow if something
is found to be true it remains to be
true
same thing if it's false it should meant
to be false but that's the crucial thing
if something is unknown in the close
World reasoning it becomes false
that's of course whether normaltonicity
comes in because once you get this
information here it may turn out to be
true it changes
and this is what you then do in open
world reasoning where then whenever
something is unknown you just look at
those possibilities and this gives you
monotronicity
so what you get then is
what you also get uh defaults and what
you get is succinctness
actually
um if you
if you take an asp specification and you
compile it into set and you do not
extend the language so no side in
Translation right then you risk an
exponential blower
but again with citing translation and
auxiliary variables you stay on the same
level that's that's one thing but let's
see this to this later
so you can do again both open the world
close World reasoning what we actually
look at are so-called stable models and
each stable model is actually a
classical model noise but the stable
model semantics does it filters the
classical models and prefers certain
certain ones
now again let's really go back and look
at like close World using databases
let's say we have a very simple database
just having one fact
so what we get then uh since we have the
alphabet A and B we get two models so
here we have them since we don't say
anything about B we had one where B is
false and one where B is true
right so what you do in a database you
always look at the minimal model
if more or less means everything is
undefined is set to fall so that's what
you get here
and here this is better so you'll get
the same thing at that end but in it you
know what what is this a here so more or
less a is actually the only only atom
that has a proof
it's a trillion proof it's stated
but the question now is how do you
generalize this idea from databases
to derivability
and let's just look at this now so now
you have we have a rule an implication
that says if if p is false then a should
be true
and now actually to establish a you need
something like a proof
and what you get now is well again you
get in in in in in a classical logic
this is just a disjunction right so you
get these three models
if you look at the minimum models you
get these two guys
but there's only one stable amount
and the reason actually is because you
take this implication here serious you
take it as a genuine connector and you
say if you want to prove things you want
to prove things
via via VIA rules
and so the way you you actually read
this here in the non-marketing studies
unless you have a proof of B
and that can't be a proof of B so this
guy is true then you can deduce a once
you get B then you when you get don't
get a anymore so this is where the
normal tendency comes from
okay so I've been talking about true
I've been talking about false and I've
been talking about unknown and this is
more or less the idea of of of of of a
logical system that has been
rediscovered Now by David Pierce I don't
know whether they are related
uh in in in in 96 who actually found out
that you can actually trace this back to
an intermediate logical logic that is
actually between intrusionistic and
classical logic
and actually he was not the first to
look at at these type of faces right
that more or less you you take
derivations as intuitionistic as
constructive the Bible was looking at
that but he really nailed it down with
with ASP and he actually rediscovered
the logic of here and there this is a
logic introduced by hiding beginning of
the 30s and some of you may also know it
another disguise as as Google
Google's G3 so the idea is you have
propositional logic but keep in mind
that this guy is a genuine connected you
don't express it uh in terms of of this
Junction now you have a very simple
crypty structure you have just two
states two models H and T and again you
can see this as a crypty structure where
you can go you can look from H into t
and of course you have you have the
reflective things and and the whenever
you have descriptive structures are
constructive like models of
intuitionistic logic whenever knowledge
you never lose knowledge when you follow
when you follow when you follow a and a
transition right so if you're under here
world and everything you know the earbud
is also proved
and this is semantically more or less
this allows you to to get it
constructible and this is more or less
if you like the simplest constructive
logic you can think of so once you add
something to this you end up with
classical
so what you then get actually is
actually a three value logic in the
sense that everything that is true in
age is provably true because you want to
have this notion of it's not only true
it's provably true in T thinks possibly
true this is more a classical world
that's how you do it in classical logic
and everything that is not in t must be
false
and then of course you have if you if
you if you have such a structure and you
are in the here world then you can
derive then this is probably true and if
you enter their world then this is like
classical logic it's possibly true right
so it's this is really like like in
classical logic now what we have now is
somehow a weaker system than classical
logic
but where everything in these two lots
of provable tools we have a proof in
your hand
this and this is generalizability the
idea that we also had in in in in
databases
and now satisfaction is more or less the
same with the on on the
uh on the basic connectives the only
thing where things differ is no
implication and implication simply means
that an implication is true if it is
true in all accessible worlds so all the
proofs actually when you have a proof
here will also have in all the words
that you can access and this implements
more of this constructive idea
and the interesting thing here is
because I know that many of you and who
know that this comes from logic programs
ah these are the negation as failure
guides well there is no negation here
negation actually is an indirect
connective because you can just simply
Define it in terms of implication and
the funny thing is you see here when
whenever you look at the negated formula
you are warped more or less you are sent
to the their world and this is classical
so more or less whenever something is
wrapped with the negation it is 3D
classic
okay just as a side remark and then of
course you can say when something is a
model but that's pretty obvious and now
just to look a little bit of truth table
for instance this
so if you add this guy for each of the
items then you get back to classical
logic
where you have a tautology is where you
have this guy
because now you have more or less three
types of literals
atoms singular and double indicated ones
and this is whenever you have something
like this it's literally like in
classical logic and this here is just a
tautology like you have it in classical
logic
right
okay just to give you a bit the flavor
of that and then
what we've seen is a logic that is
weaker than classical logic but
everything is provable and now you do
this minimization that everything is
undefined sector false
this is more or less this trick here
where you say you look at the total
interpretations that that are models of
your formula and they are minimal in the
sense you cannot find one where you can
prove less
there's really as much as this is the
smallest set you can still prove and
these guys
are the stable models
right so again um this needs to sink in
but I think it's this is a real this
this rediscovery is a real gift in the
sense that now you have a logical system
in which you can study all this all this
inferences right it's not about fixed
Point construction and things we had
before
okay let me just quickly go through that
and now okay now let's ease a little bit
up and see what this translates so I
really took you now to to I think a hard
chronological foundations
let's look at ASP again
so ASP is really it's not just about
solving it's about modeling it's about
grounding and solving so the idea is
that what you do here is is modeling but
in the sense this is a human right you
don't write normally a python or a CPC
uh procedure that generates more or less
something like machine readable code
like dimex right but then you come up
with something like a logic program
that is very close to what you have for
instance prologue then this logic
program importantly has first order
variables so it's it's it's it's a the
idea is always an encoding
um captures all instances of a class
and okay and then the grounder here
takes away all the all the variables and
more relying on help on theorem right
where all the variables systematically
replaced by by ground terms and this
grounder interestingly is too incomplete
this is just a side effect because in
the end you treat something here that is
NP or np2 or Sigma P2 right but then
here you get the propositional program
the salt and the solver computes the
stable models which which may be
classical or other ones and then you
interpret things
so and this is the language that that we
have and I don't want to go too deep
into this but what you see already is
you have rules this is the rule
but yeah of course since this was um
this since this was invented in the
Western World of course things are lying
to the left and implications are
switched around
so this is p of X is true if Q of X is
true and R of X is false then you have
types of conditionals this is quantity
the type of quantification that you have
here
then you have disjunction in the head
but this lifts you to uh to the second
level of the point on a hierarchy you
have integrity constraints and it must
not be the case that there is an X such
a Q and P hole for it then you have
cardinality constraints and you also
have Aggregates like like sum and so on
so you already see that in this language
we have basic rules and you can say that
they are translated away into into
clause in the end or whatever but here
you also have PV constraints
and here you also have multi-objective
optimization
so it's really it's it's it's going a
bit a little bit towards a silver bullet
instead it combines a lot of features
actually that that you guys all know
around but in one framework right
okay now let me let's look at how we how
we can model the traveling salesperson
problem and let's just look at an
example yes so
objective can you repeat that
it's Mexico Graphics multi-objective
optimization that is built in but you
can do other optimization on top with
other tools like aspect so multi-level
yes let's say you have a lexicographic
order on your objectives
but again there are tools that can do
Pareto for you or that can do subset or
whatever and
good so this is again the idea is that
you have a uniform problem description
uniform in the sense that you
distinguish between an encoding for the
problem class
and encoding for the problem instances
and and encoding for the problem class
should work for all the instances this
is now an instance where you just write
the standard effect you see everything
is terminated by a DOT so you have you
start this is your starting City you
have four cities then you have roads
among them with with certain distances
right and now the encoding for this here
this is just one
that I think it is easy to understand so
the first thing is here you see this
this is actually in the logically a lot
of the exclusive middle so this means
you don't have to prove anything you can
just pick you do canonistically choose
whether you travel from X to Y so you
look actually is there a road from X to
Y so well then you may choose whether
you go there
okay and again in in in sat everything
is choosable but here normally you have
to prove things except if you hear you
say you don't have to so this gives you
a guess so at that point you have guest
travel atoms and now you can elaborate
this guess so here what you do you see
what can I actually reach from my what
can I read what can I reach for my
starting note if I follow my guess so if
I have picked my starting note and in my
guess I travel from X to Y oh then I can
also visit Y and then you have here the
recursion if you visited an X and you in
your guess you travel from X to Y then
you also visit y
and again this is modeling reachability
and why can you do this in a proposition
because after all these first order
religious abbreviations for ground
instances it's normal to non-motronicity
that lets you do that because in a
monotonic approach you have to go to the
to second order logic and then you have
your your guests you now you have an
auxiliary repair what can I do with this
case how what can I visit and then here
you have integrity concern and say oh
there must not be a city that you could
not visit because you have to visit all
the cities and that cannot be a city
where I go two times or more which I
leave two times or more you go from X to
Y and that's just the inverse where you
say there must not be a city where I go
in from another node Y into x two or
more times this gives you a hamiltonian
circuit
now you add the objective function and
say oh whenever I travel on this guy I
looked at the weight and then this is
the panel
this gives you a traveling sales process
and again this can be again also from
there with the minimum that's perhaps
not so important and then you just this
is your prompt and then you launch from
Slingo this is the the encoding this is
the and this is the instance file you
launch it you get and the default mode
actually here is branch and bound even
though Kringle also allows you to do
unsatisfied call optimization this is
normally more effective but again this
is for the user
and with branch and bound the user sees
something so it's more robust in that
way that's actually why this is the
default mode so you get this solution
here you could hear the value then it
looks for another one you get a better
one and then it doesn't find a better
one and you're done but again here the
solution then is is indicated by the by
the models
so
yes another encoding and again it's
really about encoding
coding and here actually you combined a
little bit the Integrity constraint and
the guess and your your cardinality
constraints impose that there has to be
exactly one
um but and and the rest here is similar
but you see all this encoding is more
Compact and it is slightly better I'd
say right
um but really the having different
encoding and working on the encoding was
really where most of our time goes and
I remember being at the doctoral
Workshop a couple of months ago where I
was really impressed in how much
intensity goes into proof vlogging
but for us so we we try to prove these
encodings here on the first order level
right so we are not yet actually there
that we really look in the in the proofs
of the solver because first the
encodings have to be provably correct
with respect to a specification
um okay good so okay then let's look at
an application so actually I don't have
to go through this in detail but it for
instance in the company we do train this
position for a Swiss Railway not for
German Railway because they are late
but
but anyway this is a nice application
problem it's highly combinatorial but
you need different tasks so you should
do you should be able to do routing and
this is of course where ASP is really
good at you've seen this with a with a
reachability statement right then
conflict detection resolution also can
do an asp but scheduling ouch doesn't
really work
because with scheduling you have to deal
with with fine grained fine-grained
numbers and numerical domains and we
have a this is a Boolean approach
grounding will kill you so what you need
is a hybrid thing so actually one of the
workhouses in particular in our company
with lingo is is also an asp module a
theory solver we use difference logic in
it and the different constraints more or
less are than doing for us the
scheduling so what we need then in this
in this in this solution we need well
ASP to do the routing and the conflicted
section difference constraints to do the
scheduling
hybrid optimization because we have to
get we have to to to to
optimize
Boolean Boolean entities as well as
entities from the from the different
constraints
heuristic direct it's actually one thing
that I cannot talk about I'm just saying
two phrases we've talked yesterday we
talked about visits the boosting it and
this stuff right so what you can do
actually here you can add in the in the
shape and say oh if this and this
condition is true this atom should be
should the the score should be
multiplied by two or the sign should be
true or whatever so you can give also
somewhere in the encoding you can give
heuristic statements that bias uh the
the underlying heuristics and we of
course this is it has to be solved
incrementally that's what we call this
multi-shot song so what we can do
nowadays but this was more or less the
first vendor we can schedule 24 hours in
third of Switzerland in five minutes or
so which is pretty good
but still most of the most of the of the
of the of the timetables are still done
by hand but the functionality is there
you could do that so we more or less
care about cargo trains that are that
are inserted in existing in existing
schedules okay now the question is we
talked about
asp modulu
Theory solver
but you know this is not so trivial
anymore because we have a non-monotonic
system so if you have different
constraints or you have a CPU you plug
in something monotonic so what it's the
behavior of it what what should it
behave what is the semantics of it
and
um this was actually and this was
actually quite quite difficult for us to
to find out of course we first
implemented and studied it they observed
it and we actually see how we can treat
this and how we can now actually uh
verify even our systems on that respect
so if we want to do now ASP model or
theories it's not enough that we only
now take an SMP song
you also have to take the grounding
thing if you want to you want to allow
for modeling as well so you have to have
language constructs for this
so the so the approach of lingo is
actually that first of all it it has a
grammar formulas if you can specify a
grammar
then this grammar describes the new
expressions of your theory that you want
to add to your to your to your system
then you get more or less Theory ASP
programs some of this is then commuted
to to to the grounder that he knows oh I
have I have to treat them with care
because I I I I don't know their meaning
and then usually here you have a
propagator waiting
uh that that knows actually which
language constructs arrive and this guy
then deals with them right and then you
get here such such Solutions now the
first thing is of course the the the
theory that is coming or the theory
atoms the solver doesn't know has no
clue about it it's a generic framework
so if you then have something telling
like a different constraint this is now
the syntax that we use for different
constraints this is more or less like a
string
because it can pass it it can do for
instance if this may be the result of a
grounding process but it has no idea
that this string actually stands for
such a difference constraint right so if
you want to come up with semantics the
same thing
you have you always have to rely on on a
certain semantics what what these guys
here mean and you can't uh you can't
really delve in and again I will now
more or less zap you through this
because otherwise it gets too
complicated but let's first look again
at this close word reasoning thing in
why this is interesting so if we do
close word reasoning if a variable
person in a true constraint it's a sign
an appropriate value right so if X Plus
X is smaller smaller equal than two the
values are clear if a variable occurs in
no constraint
it's undefined and here this remains
undefined interestingly Peter Stuckey
whom you may know he took up this idea
and he had this lower bound idea and he
had this this thesis on on um on using
using actually this the ASP semantic in
a constraint solver which is again so he
then took wait if the domain was ordered
Peter said okay I take the lower the
lowest value I can justify
that's an idea and then in open world of
course here then if it's undefined it
takes a principle of possible values and
this is of course an issue that here you
models overcome because you just deal
with something undefined or a default
value that you plug in
okay then again you have the same you
get a then a non-monotonic framework you
have a monotonic one with all the other
which you know let's look a little bit
into this so more or less you start with
something you say okay my theory is
something like a CSP
right variables domains and then you
have atoms of them and they leave we
leave the syntax open of things we must
say we have Atomic things and there's
then we have um then from these atoms
actually we then build a formula in the
in the usual in the usual way
and since we cannot
since we cannot really go into it we we
work with valuations
so we have valuations that more or less
just map variables that occur in these
strings to domain that plus undefined
and then here we just we just you look
at these valuations from time to time as
sets because then we can say that one
valuation is has is more undefined than
another one more if you have partial
functions you could say one is more
partial than the others
okay and then you have these valuations
but from this you you then use a
denotational semantics but you in the
end you only say that well I have this
guy here it's a string and then somebody
tells me it's it's the set of valuations
associated with it and this is an
interpreting this more or less as a
difference constraint right
this is more or less and then once
you've you
see thingy you have a you have then a
satisfaction relationship over that then
you do your HTC equilibrium model
construction and what you then get is
more or less a non-monotonic semantic
for constraint satisfaction problems now
the idea is in this thing you can now
embed classical ASP plus a theory plus
another theory and they work analogical
framework and you can describe the
meaning with it so what what you what
you can then do is you can for instance
you can
uh you can study language fragments so
for instance which of them actually are
generic enough you can you can study um
program Transformations there's one
thing also to to remember in a in in
classical logic you can substitute
equivalent sub formulas
here you cannot substitute equivalent
subform it's because the logic is
context dependent
you need stronger notes like strong
equivalents so if you want to optimize
your program and you have written a
specification for ASB model of
difference constraint and you want to
optimize this by doing Transformations
or whatever it's important that you have
such a logic and this actually we can do
with this system now
so I know that I torture you by showing
you this but it pays up that's that's
the message I want to pass along right
um
good then
um oh I'm actually much faster than I
thought but Mark will be happy so what
didn't I talk about
so the first thing and this is something
I really love because here you have a
solving approach that has syntax
right you have you have an encoding you
have a symbol table you output things
and so on and so forth so we can do meta
programming so you can actually write
a meta ASP solver half a page it's an
encoding because actually what you what
what Gringo does it can it can take a
program pause it and represent as a set
of facts and then you you write your
encoding that interprets the program
very cute thing then we have qualitative
and quantity of optimization not not
necessarily built in but usually
compiled down where you can actually
compose preference you can say you want
Pareto of a minimization and the
maximization and you can arbitrarily
Nest things and this you can compile
this away I already talked about
heuristic programming
which which are more or less statements
like rules where you say if certain
conditions are true and you don't derive
something there's no propagation but you
say the new bias this thing or or you
you do the other way around you say
don't take this
divide divide the the realistic value so
for instance
optimization
when you when you want to compute
opt in an applicant
to get the optional solution it just
takes way too long but what you can
really boost with this is the
convergence to the optimum solution
right because if you have a minimization
statement and you just say oh I
preferably assign these guys false and
perhaps choose them first
and usually this this helps to converge
but actually always to be careful with
this because the unsatisfiability proof
at the end will be really slowed down so
you converge you find much better
Solutions quicker but so and there are
different applications of it then of
course I already you already saw that
there's Theory solving inside there's an
incremental thingy we recently uh
extended started extending things in a
temporal fashion with linear and dynamic
reason to be what we want to do a little
bit
push forward but what actually you guys
did in sat planning where we want to do
how can we do with ASP planning and
again there we head first to think about
what type of uh modeling languages we
use and what we recently just added and
that just was bragging about this tomato
is visualization so we have this
instance we have this encoding and now
we usually have a visualization encoding
where you write a couple of lines where
you take you add this to the program
right and whatever the solution is you
then visualize this right away because
and you describe this within ASP so you
get also don't go out you get visualized
and it's it's
again it's three four five lines nothing
more right
good and if you well if you play for a
module do you want to but look at this
just go to to our site here put Tesco
and then perhaps do a recap the
take-home method first of all
ASP is not just about soliding it's
about modeling grounding and solving and
I would say if
big emphasis like lies actually on the
modeling side on the modeling here so I
those of you who run Ubuntu or Debian
may have noticed that there is ASP cut
for software configuration this is
actually developed in our group within
the Slingo and I remember when we
developed this in the end we had
10 or 11 alternative encodings
different principles and then we just
had to to well to to to heat up the
department and and run for one or two
weeks the cluster to see experimentally
what really comes out right but but it
is it's very important to study
different ways of encoding and grounding
is of course one of the first
bottlenecks you have to observe how how
do your variables
um combinatorically
um more or less lead to certain
explosions when you when you instance it
but one thing of course is is nice as
well he's grounded since they since they
know about the stable models I mean
about the close World reasoning they can
do according simplifications so if there
is for instance an atom produce if you
can never produce an atom in a head you
know that it's false and you can
propagate this this this throw okay
anyway
uh then again this this type of thing
where do the Technologies come from
again grounding is basically a similar
if database evaluation logic programming
is more or less where where things begin
also with negations failure KR for the
knowledge representation language and
and such models which which boosts a lot
the the solving so Benny once said that
for instance in the code of Class 10
constitute a stat solver all the rest
are more or less to support all the
other inference mechanisms enumeration
uh intersection Computing the
intersection the union or of all the
optimal models and and you can you can
do you can combine them in different
things in a way then you you actually
what what the action solving boils down
is is actually start modulo several
theories
and yeah I think this is it again and as
I say it's fun right so
um I can keep in mind that the whole
infrastructure applies equally well to
set and this we have SIMPLE tables you
have visualization you have all these
nice features
on that
the questions
foreign
last example the Ubuntu one you said you
had to heat up the building are there
any takeaway messages like high-level
things that you could learn from that
experimentation
there is an omnipresent message you take
home
that you can never recover from a crappy
encoding
so you always have to get the encoding
right because you know we of course also
use then um like algorithm configuration
tools in the end and all that type of
stuff or the solver actually has
pre-configurations and people are really
tempted to tune with the server but it
will never work if you didn't get your
encoding right
anything about what that writing coding
is because all of these 10 12 options
were written by people like you who are
experts but only one of them was good at
the end right yeah but again yeah again
but even we couldn't after because there
were different approaches to it and and
that was is of course an extreme case
that's why I talk about it right
but you need experience but on the other
hand I think basic computer science
education is if you look at a rule do
you really need all the variables right
which okay could you perhaps project
things out in a certain way that the
combinatory could do videos these are
Elementary things that we all
we all
right so in modeling this unknown to say
close World reasoning or close minor
reason or whatever call it
so what extent is a variable unknown
in a way
actually from a logical perspective what
you could say is you could you would you
only need some of the truths that you're
true right that things are provably true
and everything that is not derivable in
a certain way you could just live on
undefined if the thing is completely
underivable don't have to throw it away
what does it appear in the first place
first of all you don't see it in the
modeling language right and it's in the
cement we use it in the semantics
so it's in the Boolean semantics we are
not using it
it's rather actually when you have when
you have a when you have a variable over
numeric domain right
um it's not clear what what the default
value should be right in in in a logical
setting the default value for something
that is unknown that you want to close
what we decided to false like in a
database it's it's it's natural but in a
and as I mentioned Peter Stuckey was was
actually proposing whenever you've
ordered domains to commit either to the
to the to the least or the or the or the
largest element right yeah this is
related to the second question actually
and you treat all unknowns as one symbol
let's say you as you do know in your
slides usually in for example we can
have a Boolean evaluation where you have
different levels or possibility of being
true yeah is there anything uh no we're
not familiar okay
thank you
it will be my second question but yeah I
think was slide 22 is that too if it's
not too hard to go back to that if you
can stand me this is quite low level but
I think it might help my understanding
of how this works
this one uh yes you know the cardinality
constraints with travel in and travel
out
uh yes that that one you have to write
it twice for come incoming and outgoing
I would it not be the same if you wrote
it once or visit it actually
hear you one of them would suffice you
don't need a second one but when you're
at this this is a typical thing where
you have to know a little bit think a
bit of being holy but if you add the
second one you let the solver propagate
much much better
okay so you would not you don't you only
need one of them
but propagation is is so much stronger
if you have both of them but what I
guess my question is slightly different
why is visiting not the same as coming
coming in and out I thought that was
roughly the definition of visit no he he
you just check what is reachable okay
right well here you check that you only
Traverse a note once
right you could you could you could have
a guess actually where you where you
where you travel to a node several times
and it would be visible visited it would
be reachable so visited means visitable
reachable reachable it's just like we
should build a Transit closure room and
so on
foreign
so I was just recently exposed to uh
clingo and I found that it's really
expressive in terms of modeling and
encoding which is really nice but I also
found I was less confident when encoding
things in ASP because there are some
things that are not very trivial to
beginners such as double negations such
as a citricity of derivations so
sometimes I feel that I input the same
uh input different encodings but they
should have the same logic meanings but
they output the different things so how
do we come on that well first of all for
example negation
I wouldn't use it so I I rarely come
across it that I would need to use it
right then um it's it's I think it's a
matter of of culture so
I think uh Andrei right yeah yeah so you
were first exposed to ASP and then for
us to do set
and he had a hard time
and if you called out
and then and I think for you it maybe it
went the other way around right so but
but here and and I had it also applies
to me so I grew up with Chris prologue
for instance and I had prob I had
problems letting go
right and and
so first I think the most important
thing here is to is to realize that
things have to be derived to a certain
extent and to get this notion that
because in in in in a monotone you can
set you have a variable and
automatically takes values here you have
to derive it with a value
and this is something that that takes I
think sometimes some sometimes
but visit our group you will get get
infected very soon and the virus will
settle in good idea thank you
other questions
here again
[Applause]
who's gonna